a landmark debate as Parliament special
committee on tax rulings tackles an
issue close to citizens tax justice
specifically member states deals with
multinationals reducing their liability
to a fraction of everyone else's karkash
call Kelly mientas no spaces cleavage in
see the quasi una comment so vegetables
can't avenge ashkenazi medicine Pradesh
yes horse English Oh Sasha you see da
dong como esta situación a tu tambien te
gusta de Glace behandlung Fernandez is
the centrality Marcel VFS nine escaped
con a con fair and soya vetiver measures
recommended include taxation where
profits are made more transparency and
information sharing and ending tax
competition between EU members we have
managed to proceed to a series
compilation really of more or less
everything that exists in terms of
doubtful practices in in corporate tax
matters the committee was to be wound up
soon but when demands for documents went
unheeded it asked for a six-month
extension the member states and also the
European Commission have denied the
Parliament access to the critical
documents we are hopeful that we get now
access to these documents so that we can
establish political responsibility
before that starts the committee's
recommendations go to the vote
16 each other